so as we continue to lead up to civil
war - what I want to do here is expand
on my video about the Celestials by
focusing on their history throughout the
Marvel Universe and what I'm hoping is
that at the end of all this you'll have
a strong understanding of their race
going into Civil War - and the actions
of Ulysses as part of the Inhumans so
despite having been a mainstay in the
Marvel Universe since its formation the
origin of the Celestials has remained
entirely unexplained where stories like
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four and
Marjorie loos astonishing x-men number
61 have depicted the Rays as cosmic
level in the origin of the multiverse
itself these conflicting stories
represent the lack of cohesiveness
regarding the origin of the Celestials
and how they came to be while their
origin in and of itself is not a
necessity to understand their place
within the Marvel cosmos at the very
least it would fit in nicely with the
fandom and for structure and comics that
said if we go by the information for
Marjorie Liu's astonishing x-men run at
the beginning of all things and
presumably following the creation of a
Living Tribunal by the one above all the
Celestials stood as the sole occupants
of all reality creating the multiverse
and all universes within the Celestials
spend a brunt of their early years
seeding life throughout the cosmos by
both creating life directly as well as
expanding their own ranks by planting a
celestial egg within the center of a
planet allowing it to gestate for
millions of years after which it would
emerge consuming the planet in the
process to this end the role of Galactus
as the devourer of worlds was deemed a
necessity by the cosmic entity eternity
under the idea that Galactus was equal
to the Celestials and power and consumed
worlds in order to keep the Celestials
themselves from overpopulating the
universe however because of Celestials
recognize the purpose of Galactus in
relation to themselves they in turn
created death now whether or not the
Celestials created the entity death
itself or a means for which death to act
within the confines of the universe is
never made clear and in truth we can
draw our own conclusions here but the
fact remains that during this time the
Celestials came into conflict with a
race called the aspirants covered in
Iron Man vol 5 issue number 13 where the
origin of the aspirins is left
unexplained writer Kieron Gillen
established that the race had gone to
war with the
Celestials during this conflict at the
beginning of all things while the
Celestials came out as the victors their
numbers had been reduced from billions
to only a handful following this the
Celestials entered into a structured
order traversing the universe and
actively involving themselves in the
evolution of various organisms as an
example the mutants deviants and
Eternals of earth as well as status of
the titan Eternals exists as byproducts
of the Celestials to sidetrack here in
the early years of Earth's existence the
Celestials traveled to earth in the form
of the first host and tested Neanderthal
man by experimenting on them creating
the deviants eternals and the mutants
where the mutant gene would not emerge
until several thousand millennia in the
future the Eternals and deviants emerged
almost immediately engaging in a war for
dominion over earth because the eternal
sought enlightenment through the use of
their vast cosmic powers while some
stayed behind most eternals took to the
stars
leaving the deviants to wage war on
those left behind as well as build
cities and rural a majority of the earth
from their capital known as Lemuria
however at around 18,000 BC the
Celestials had travel to earth in the
form of a second host for the purpose of
enacting the second of four tests on
their experiments finding the Eternals
had struck packs of non-intervention
with the Olympian gods as well as living
in tranquility on earth the deviants
existed at the other end of the spectrum
viewing the Celestials as a threat to
the rule the deviants attacked and were
swiftly obliterated with their number
reduced to near zero taking refuge
underground and abandoning their various
settlements the actions of the deviants
paved way for humanity and the Inhumans
to seize control of the surface electing
their own cities and advancing their own
technologies in something to also take
note of here is that during the culling
of the deviance by Aaron the judge the
celestial who determined whether
different species were deemed worthy or
unworthy when the second house had
initially arrived timely The Dreaming
celestial had witnessed the deviants
place on earth and their seizing control
of humanity as slaves and tending to
wipe out all life and start anew where
era Shem had reviewed the order and
instead orchestrated the calling of the
deviants when time avid intervened he
was attacked by the other Celestials and
imprisoned on earth where he was later
discovered by Earth's inhabitants
including mr. sinister and cyclopses
extinction team during mass fractions
run of uncanny
now jumping forward to 1150 ad give or
take a bit and the first documented
encounter with the celestial by modern
mutants as far as I've been able to
locate in Marvel Comics came within sub
on your taking place between the
emergence of his powers and his first
encounter with a time traveler cable and
Saban noir had traveled the world
unaware that he existed as one of a
handful of individuals known as
externals which is to say mutants who
were truly immortal and unable to die
encountering another external named
Hollow Shan who had been siphoning the
powers of a celestial ship while unaware
of his true capabilities after defeating
Roshan and seizing control of the ship
for himself and sub on newer remained
unable to access its technologies until
his battle with cable as I was explained
in my apocalypse video after which in
Saban noir had gained access to the ship
and came face to face with Isan the
searcher the existing is one of the
Celestials that wiped out the deviant
capital of Lemuria as well as the
celestial who appeared in the guardians
of the galaxy film asan's conversation
with in Saban noir offered a pact that
if noir chose to use the celestial
technology for himself he would go
forward as one of the most powerful
beings on earth but experienced pain
beyond imagining at some point in the
future where n Saban nor would accept
the offer and go on to become one of the
x-men's most deadly foes the third host
of the Celestials arrived following the
abduction of earth into the world true
of addressed by the Asgardians because
this era of Asgardian history had seen
Odin coming into the position of king
the primitive nature of humanity gave
way to belief in godly presences chief
among them being the Asgardians and the
Olympians where the Olympians use
Olympus as the portal to their realm
accessible only by those with the blood
of gods Asgard hit from the Bifrost
bridge and included earth as part of its
cosmic pantheon viewing the will of
Asgard is being powerful enough to
influence the lives of humanity guided
them to future advancement as opposed to
letting humans evolve on their own
the third house of the Celestials
appeared during Thor annual number seven
removing his knowledge of the deviants
at eternals as well as warning the
Asgardians not to intervene lest they be
destroyed
following this the Celestials visited
earth for a fourth time continued to use
a fourth host to determine whether or
not life on Earth should continue or be
destroyed while these guardians and
other earthly gods maintained the pact
of non-intervention because earth served
as part of the world tree of a drasil
which would have collapsed and severed
all connections to the nine realms how
to earth been destroyed
Odin alongside Heimdall in Gaia at the
biological mother of Thor and the
physical manifestation of Earth itself
had presented nine individuals referred
to as the young gods who represented the
best of humanity within the confines of
the mental moral emotional and physical
sphere during the earth worthy of
continued survival in that the young
gods represented humanity's capability
of advancement into the upper echelon of
the universal pantheon the presence of
the for celestial host went on to reveal
that instead of outright creating
mutants per se instead the Celestials
had manipulated the genes of early
humanity providing the potential for
genetic mutants to take effect
while this bit of information was left
ambiguous and Marvel College regarding
the purpose of the Celestials within the
universe itself in 1997 as part of the
heroes reborn and heroes returned events
after having created a pocket universe
and resurrecting the heroes who died
during their battle with Ocelot Franklin
Richards encountered Ashima at the
celestial who would take in human form
revealing the Franklin's vast
reality-warping powers had not only
resurrected the dead heroes within a
universe he had created
but the Franklin himself was a pinnacle
of the celestial experiments on
humankind that said whether it was
because Marvel had been in the process
of introducing newer concepts or else
because there was no real place for them
within the goings-on of Earth as far as
I've been able to tell the Celestials
remained completely absent from the
earthly landscape instead the race made
a majority of their appearances within
both Neil Gaiman and Charles NAAFS runs
of Eternals in volumes three in volume
four respectively both of which went on
to introduce concepts like the fulcrum a
presumed aspect of the one above all and
the idea that Celestials meet with the
fulcrum during their deaths as part of
the journey to the afterlife now where
much of this remains ambiguous even if
it was only for the purpose of offering
a catalyst to expand on the relationship
between Reed and Franklin Jonathan
Hickman's fantastic for a future
foundation event introduced the notion
that Celestials experience emotion in
the same capacity as humans and are
capable of falling prey to those
feelings taking place in future
foundation number 14 title 27 minutes
following the introduction of the
Council of reeds as a multi Barroso
conglomerate of Reed Richards who all
came together for the purpose to solve
the problem
everything the Nexus of reality was
invaded by the mad Celestials of Earth
four to eight zero who had come to view
themselves as gods seizing control of
their own reality and looking to take
over the multiverse the mad Celestials
invaded the earth-616 continuity leading
to the arrival of Franklin Richards from
the future where he transformed Galactus
into his Herald however aside from this
bit of expansion within the pages of
Avengers vol 5 a New Avengers vol 3 as
part of Hickman's lead-up to Secret Wars
the absence of the Celestials beyond the
Future Foundation and Fantastic Four
stories was explained by way of the
revelation that the beyonders of wild
space had systematically been entering
universes and wiping them out entirely
including the Celestials covered in New
Avengers vol 3 issue number 30 with Reed
Richards having tasked Hank Pym with
travelling to the multiverse in an
effort to prevent its collapse Hank Pym
had stumbled across a last-ditch battle
between the beyonders and all of the
remaining cosmic entities of a
multiverse wiping out all of the
entities including the Celestials and
eventually The Living Tribunal when the
collapse of the multiverse occurred with
Secret Wars issue number zero leading
into the introduction of battleworld
and the main Secret Wars event at its
conclusion going into all-new
all-different marvel all new Galactus
conversation with molecule man provided
no indication of the Celestials return
following the multiverse as recreation
by molecule man Franklin Richards and
Reed to this end while the Ultimates
comics under out Ewing and Kenneth
bracha four would see the reappearance
of Thanos as a catalyst for introducing
Ulysses of the Inhumans who had the
power to see the future one of his
visions came in the form of the
celestial destructor of another reality
who had entered earth using a rift in
space providing this information to
shield and sword the sentient world
observation and response department the
combined forces of the Inhumans The
Ultimates The Avengers and various other
heroes allow for a distraction while
Doctor Strange Scarlet Witch and the
mystics of the Marvel Universe use their
abilities to return the destructor to
his home reality
and seal the breach leading into the
official start a civil war - with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end and I will catch you
guys either priests